mediators are calling for Sudan's
warning sites to extend their week-long
humanitarian ceasefire the truce between
the Army and the rapid support forces is
due to expire on Monday evening its
Brokers Saudi Arabia and the U.S say an
extension will allow the delivery of
urgent aid the UN says more than half of
Sudan's population is in need of
humanitarian Assistance or hibber
Morgan's joining us now from onderman so
the U.S and the Saudi Arabia are calling
for an extension they're still
describing the current ceasefire is
imperfect do we have any indication What
Might Have Been achieved by the
ceasefire so far
well the whole purpose of this
humanitarian ceasefire that was signed
between the Army and the rapid support
workforces was to open humanitarian
corridors for Aid to be able to reach
the millions were still traps here in
the capital and other parts of the
country now we know that there are many
people in many parts of the capital
especially the Northern parts who have
not been able to uh to get or receive
aid from Aid organizations and we also
know that many Aid organizations were
unable to deliver Aid to those in need
and that's only here in the capital so
one of the main purposes of the
ceasefire was not achieved which is to
try to reach as many people as possible
including in the region of Darfur now
the other purpose of the ceasefire was
in the word itself ceasefire there
should be no fighting between the rsf
and the Sudanese Army for possible uh
longer term and more permanency is far
to be negotiated between the two sides
but from the very first minutes of the
ceasefire coming into effect we were
able to hear explosions we were able to
hear gunfire and that was the case on
Sunday morning as well there's been
intense fighting between the rapid
support forces and the Sudanese Army in
helfaya Bridge which is the bridge that
connects the city of durman to the
northern part of the capital so while
there was so much hope pinned on the
ceasefire by the mediators specifically
on the ground many people say that they
did not see the ceasefire manifest and
for the past six days in many parts of
the capital so the sound of heavy
artillery gunfire and airstrikes were
heard
yeah having you mentioned the region of
the area of Darfur there and and as I
understand it in terms of things
intensifying I believe the governor of
Darfur is calling for citizens to arm
themselves what more can you tell us
about that
well it comes as a result of the
increase in their attacks by Arab Allied
or rsf Allied Arab militias in the
western region of Darfur now for more
than a week that region which is already
coming out of 20 years of Civil War and
where many people have been displaced
and Service delivery has been poor
because of conflict uh additional
fighting between the rapid support
forces their Arab Allied militias and uh
ethnic Dark Forest has led to uh
thousands of people being displaced to
neighboring Chad others unable to access
basic facilities like health services so
the governor of Darfur has called on
civilians to try to protect themselves
he said that both men and women should
arm themselves against those attacks
attacks which witnessed markets being
raised properties being looted
government institutions being destroyed
but many people are criticizing him now
he has an army he's a he's a former
Rebel group that signed a peace deal
with the government in 2020 and has a
large Force so many people are saying
that he should also play a bigger role
in of calling on people to arm
themselves and that as the governor of
therefore and as a person with armed
group arms Fighters he should protect
the people in Darfur Eva thank you very
much indeed that's Heather Morgan
bringing us up to date from undermann